Your immune system might not be sentient,
but it can get amnesia.
Sort of.
It’s pretty neat, and also scary.
Hello everyone, a happily measles-free Amy
with you on DNews today.
Since 1968, we’ve been immunizing kids for
measles, with the same vaccine we use today.
But, as more and more kids got vaccinated,
scientists noticed something weird.
There was a significant drop in deaths from
measles, which was expected, but also a drop
in deaths from other infectious diseases.
And no one knew why… until now!
A paper in the journal Science looked at monkeys
that had measles and found their immune systems
had a sort of amnesia after being infected.
This “immune amnesia” caused a years-long
disabling of the immune system against other
diseases.
See, our immune system is made up of organs,
cells, and proteins that together protect
the body from harmful organisms.
When a foreign cell with an antigen -- a protein
on the surface of bacteria, fungi and viruses
-- enters the body, the immune system reacts
to fight it, protecting the body from illness.
We get sick when your immune system meets
a pathogen it hasn’t encountered before.
But when it meets a familiar pathogen, it
binds with the antigens on it’s surface
and the body can fight off the disease.
Your immune system gets weak when you’re
sick, but it bounces back imbued with a memory
of the disease it fought.
Now, if the same pathogen enters the body
a second time, you can fight it off.
This is why your mom might have encouraged
you to play with your friend who had the chicken
pox.
Once you get it, your body has the defence
for it and you won’t get it again!
But the measles changes this whole behaviour!
For some reason, immune systems in people
with the measles lose any memory of how to
fight other diseases.
Once the immune system bounces back, the new,
regenerated white blood cells only remember
the measles; they have no memory of other
diseases the body previously fought!
And that’s why the measles vaccine helps
protect against other diseases!
We’ve seen this play out before.
That same paper in the journal Science compared
child mortality rates in the US, UK, and Denmark.
Using a complex statistical model, they found
that in all three countries the rise in infectious
diseases -- specifically pneumonia, diarrhoeal
diseases, and meningitis — matched rates
of immune amnesia following measles; that
“immune amnesia” lasted on average for
27 months.
So, for more than two years after contracting
measles, kids were more susceptible to potentially
deadly diseases.
Rates of infectious disease were linked to
measles cases so strongly the team was able
to correlate childhood mortality rates with
measles outbreaks.
What does this mean?
Well without the vaccine, if you get chickenpox
when you’re 4, then measles when you’re
5, you’re susceptible to chickenpox again
for another two years!
For young kids, this can mean exposure to
measles in a 2 year old can reset the immune
system to that of a newborn, leaving the toddler
at risk to other potentially life-threatening
diseases.
Today, the measles has been almost eradicated
in the United States in the last half century,
taking other diseases with it.
So... do you need another reason to vaccinate
against measles?
But does this mean you should expose your
kids to measles?
We talked about measles parties in this video
right here.
So anyone out there get measles and other
nasty complications?
Let us know in the comments below, be sure
to like this video, and subscribe so you never
miss an episode of DNews.